it's time to get reacquainted I never
been scared of a little contact oh my
God it is an honor to get to stay here
with you man seriously I don't know if
anyone's told you this yet but the
theater that I sat in and watched your
film people were cheering like they were
actually at Dodger Stadium hey that's
what I'm talking about I love it I love
it you know you know you get you get you
get those you know in these movies you
know that's like a real Testament of
like how you're how you're you know how
your fight's going so so to hear that uh
I haven't been in an actual audience yet
to see it so that's that's all it sounds
awesome this is the first sports film
ever shot with IMAX cameras what does it
mean to you that you not only starred in
but you helmed it
that's crazy because I found that out
after I actually shot it so that wasn't
even something that I knew as I was as I
was shooting uh as I was like shooting
the movie but it feels if that's that's
cool that's like a ESPN stat you know
what I'm saying that sounds pretty cool
I'll I'll I'll I'll take it man it's
pretty it's pretty cool if you can
measure your life in ESPN stats I'd say
you're doing a pretty good job so
this is the first sports movie ever shot
with IMAX cameras yeah what does that
mean to you to be involved in something
like that it's an awesome project also I
saw the movie The Other Day loved your
performance but what does it mean to be
involved in that kind of History
well you said it's historic you know uh
it means a lot I think the rocky
franchise and uh consequently the Creed
franchise
um are the biggest most popular most
iconic sports franchise in the history
of Cinema and so it only is only fitting
that
um it reaches the highest level of uh
the similar experience in IMAX and so uh
to step into it and to be in those
fights you know to actually be a
participant not just in the movie but
participant
um I mean it's a great deal your
character in this franchise as a
musician and you are actually a pretty
great musician yourself thanks I feel
like I had grip in a playlist after I
watched the first time thank you so much
so I'm curious should we be expecting
like a Tessa Thompson project at some
point I don't know I think that ship has
sailed in a way when we made the first
film honestly like I I was I was I had
been singing in a band like I would I
was you know I was making more music
frankly during that time and then I made
when we made the music for creed I think
I had like 11 songs
um I could have put out a record during
during that time
um there was something really freeing
about making music for a character and
not for me there was something kind of
liberating about that experience and I
still love music I'm I'm like it's huge
it's Paramount in my work but I think
the things that I'm interested in now
um I don't know that that's gonna be
what you see from me I think you will
see new things I think you'll see me
break new ground but I don't think it's
gonna be
in a record I feel that well I'm excited
to see you if you ever do change your
mind I'll be one of the first okay okay
I'll drop it to you maybe if I just do
some sneaky tracks I'll drop them to you
please I will oh my God that would be
the experience in a lifetime
um if you could experience any film on
IMAX again for the first time what would
it be and why oh my God that's such a
good question oh any if I experience any
film again in my mind
[Music]
oh wow probably probably
Jurassic Park the first Jurassic Park
are probably really good in IMAX oh
actually that sounds really fun probably
the movie's uh sunshine have you ever
seen that one at all yeah it was awesome
and just like that deck when they were
just looking at you know saying the sun
all the time would be incredible and
like IMAX so like yeah I want to ask you
why should fans experience Creed 3 and
IMAX
I think it's gonna you're gonna
experience the fights like you never
could before you know um I think it you
know you'll be immersed in sound and and
visual content and make you feel like
you're right there in the ring you know
you if you feel like the referee you'll
be right there you know in between these
two fighters
um and just everything from you know the
feet on the canvas and what that sounds
like to you know the impact of the
punches to the lack thereof sound you
know I think this is truly incredible so
um you know IMAX gave me the ability to
shoot these fights you know like I've
never we that we could never do before
um and I think it's definitely
definitely worth it I would say one last
question for you
um you know you've kind of done it all
right like you've been leading man
you've been a star you've directed this
film now what's next for you what
stories do you want to tell
I haven't thought about it yet honestly
uh this thing this training has been
moving so fast you know and and
um you know just trying to finish this
movie and get it out to the world and
then I can kind of reset look at the lay
of the land you understand what's going
on and then make a decision from there
but I definitely want to direct again
um I just don't know exactly what let's
help you use IMAX cameras of course